to me so there's of course physics and
computational uh fascinating questions
here but to me there's a practical
psychological question which is you know
how do you create a virtual reality
world
that um is as compelling and not
necessarily even as realistic but
almost as realistic
but as compelling or more compelling
Than Physical reality
because something tells me it's not it's
not very difficult in a in a
full history of human civilization
though that is an interesting
kind of simulation to me because that
feels like it's doable in the next 100
years creating a world where we're all
prefer to live in the digital world and
not like a visit but like it's like
your scene is insane no like you're
required it's unsafe to live outside of
the virtual world and uh it's
interesting to me from an engineering
perspective how to build that because
I'm somebody that sort of loves video
games and it seems like you can create
incredible worlds there and stay there
and that's a it's a different
the question then creating a ultra high
resolution High Fidelity simulation of
physics but if that world inside a video
game is
as consistent as the physics of our
reality that you can have your own
scientists in that world that trying to
understand that physics World it might
look different
that eventually forget you know give it
give it long enough they might forget
about their origins of being once
biological and assume this is their only
reality especially if you're now born
you know uh well certainly if you're
born but even if you're eight years old
or something when you first started
wearing the headset
yeah or you have a memory wipe when you
go in I mean it it also kind of maybe
speaks to this issue of like neuralink
and how do we keep up with AI in our
world
if you want to augment your intelligence
um perhaps one way of competing and the
one of your impetuses for going into
this digital reality would be to be
competitive intellectually with
um artificial intelligences that you
could trivially augment your reality if
your brain was itself artificial but
I mean one one skept is my voice had
about that is is whether it's more of a
first tough question but how much is
that really you if you do a mind upload
is this just a duplicate of your
memories that thinks it's you versus
truly a transference of your contrast
stream into that reality and I think
when you uh
it's almost like the teleportation
device in Star Trek
um but with teleportation quantum
teleportation you can kind of rigorously
show that
um that you know all as long as all of
the
quantum numbers are exactly duplicated
as you transfer over it truly is from
the universe's perspective in every way
indistinguishable from what was there
before it really is in principle of you
and all the sense of being you versus
creating a duplicate clone and uploading
memories uh to that human body or a
computer that would
surely be a a discontinuation of that
conscious experience by virtually the
fact you've multiplied it and so I
I would be hesitant about uploading for
that reason I would see it mostly as my
own killing myself and having some
um AI duplicate of me that persists in
this world but is not truly my
experience typical
20th century human with an attachment to
this particular singular instantiation
of brain and body
how silly humans used to be used to have
rotary phones and
um
and and other silly things